good morning everyone my name is rissy
and i take this opportunity to introduce
you to this interesting piece of work i
was involved in in collaboration with my
colleague away whereby we assessed the
current status of traditional and
genomic screening in newborns with a
special focus in africa
did you know that 5 to 10 years from now
every bobby born will have their genome
sequenced at birth
well i look forward to living in such a
world as hypocrites once said it is
important to know which individual has a
condition than the condition which an
individual has and one such application
of this anecdote is the newborn
screening which is also known as the
baby's first test this particular
technique has been shown to improve the
overall quality of life of neonates
since its introduction to decades ago
this is through early detection and
prevention of inborn congenital
disorders most of these conditions which
are genetic in nature if not treated
early may lead to lifelong disabilities
and sometimes death this particular
technique is currently being used in
routine clinical setups whereby neonates
have been diagnosed for conditions
likely to manifest in their adults early
childhood as well as inlet adults onset
therefore
our study aimed to document the
currently existing efforts on the use of
both traditional and genomic screening
methods with
a special focus in africa
when it comes to our methodology we
conducted a comprehensive literature
review on fully free text permit
articles and the keys such times used
including nato screening newborn
screening africa traditional genomics
the filtration process
is based on the criteria on my right
whereby for instance if an at the
publication date was set to a maximum of
10 years and fanatical maybe was
published in 1986 it would be exempted
from the review process this was
followed by a comprehensive critical
assessment of the abstract contact on
the relevance of the study so what did
we find out
in terms of the screening methods the
traditional newborn screening methods
have progressed from immunoassays to
fluoresomatic assays to fluoroenzymatic
immunoassays and to the famously known
tandema spectrometry this particular
technique was a game changer in newport
screening whereby it enabled the screen
the screening process to move from just
a singular disorder to multiple
metabolic disorders at ago
which brings me to our current state
whereby we have genomic newborn
screening and some of the methods
include whole exome sequencing whole
genome sequencing chain final base
sequencing and targeted sequencing in
the gene panel based sequencing which
seems to be the most preferred method we
have companies designing a
specific set of genes in a cheap based
format and using targeting specific
conditions when it comes to targeted
sequencing we could target specific
genomic regions of spec of of the gene
to screen for specific disorders so what
are our overall comparators when it
comes to traditional
newborn screening programs developed
countries have functional operational
and legislatively established and based
programs incorporated in routine
healthcare systems and these are
actually operational in states in the
u.s some countries such as canada china
and the uk however when it comes to the
sub-saharan africa majority are they at
the infancy stages of establishing
traditional nbs programs however it is
not worthy to know that spain in
republic and ghana as the only african
countries reported in literature to have
comprehensive nps programs when it comes
to prioritization of conditions
congenital hypothyroidism is the most
cost-effective skin for conditioned
globally however in sub-saharan africa
hemoglobinopathies and glucose
6-phosphate diffusion seems to be
prioritized this is the case in india
and some parts of asia when it comes to
the screening capacity 5 to 10 disorders
are screened for at a time in developed
countries and most of these conditions
most of these nations have compulsory
number screening programs for specific
disorders in some regions however in
sub-saharan africa only singular
discovers a screen for and then i don't
sharing resources with existing
immunization and hiv screening programs
when it comes to social funding and
based programs are part of the national
health and regulatory and legislative
systems and are usually funded by the
government in developed countries having
sub-saharan africa like other
under-resourced settings we have most
programs rely on funding from
non-governmental organizations and world
wishes when it comes to genomic newborn
screening the u.s uk and china through
the government of set aside funding to
conduct pilot studies for
exploration of genomic mbas however in
africa their limited efforts whereby
countries such as south africa ghana and
tanzania have attempted to document
efforts in gnbs by screening for
specific singular disorders so generally
as we have seen from this table africa
is currently under resource and cannot
handle genomic newborn screening what
are some of the arising challenges for
traditional nps we have issues such as
implementation sustainability expertise
acquisition and cost in terms of
equipment agent diagnosis and lifelong
treatment
and when it comes to genomic nba is the
issue of true consent whereby we want to
know well if the parent gave consent for
the
genomic data of the infant to be
obtained would they be permitted once
they reach legal age to retract the
information online if need be other
issues are include data privacy just of
conclusion for conditions result
interpretation and reporting and method
validation when it comes to our overall
findings from this study it is not
worthy to know that africa is still at
the initial status of implementing
traditional mbas
as a result of limited access to
resources for genomic newborn screening
sickle cell disease is the most screened
for disorder in sub-saharan africa this
could be attributed to the high
prevalence rate of the disorder in these
parts of the world
most developed countries have set aside
funding to conduct research on the
potential clinical utility of gnbs
however there exists a great discordance
on the selection criteria for the gene
this is inclusion in currently existing
ngs based panels so we have multiple
panels from different parts of the world
however the conditions that are being
included vary greatly and that would be
something that we need to come up with a
consensus
agreement on which conditions to include
for genomic screening compared to
developed nations few efforts have been
made to implement genomic nipple
screening in africa our findings
therefore reveal the unpreparedness of
both resources and the resource system
to prevent gnbs at scale when it comes
to future prospects this study sets the
foundation for exploration african
genomic newborn screening based on a
proposed african specific gnps panel
this password will be realized in
accordance on setup by leveraging
publicly available neonatal sequence
data sets so at the moment i'm currently
involved in a study whereby we're
leveraging publicly accessible data in a
bid to validate
our african specific gnps panel which
was developed as a result of this
particular survey some limitation of the
studies that it was based on fully free
text that it was available in pubmed and
other potentially useful articles may
not have been included and this can be
attributed the limited access to funding
for this particular research so these
are my references and thank you ladies
and gentlemen kindly feel free to reach
me through my contact details as shown
in the screen i look forward to hearing
from you have a good day